[Música]
en este momento en el mundo existen más
de 8 mil millones de dispositivos
conectados a internet mil millones más
de habitantes en el planeta esta cifra
es todavía más impactante si pensamos
que hace apenas 30 años tres décadas el
número de dispositivos móviles
conectados a internet era virtualmente
en qué momento los dispositivos
tecnológicos conectados a internet no
sobrepasaron a los seres humanos en qué
momento el foro económico mundial con
datos de la onu y del reporte edison
apunta que esto sucedió aproximadamente
en el 2015 como podemos ver en esta
gráfica
ustedes pueden ver que más o menos en el
2015 entre los 7.300 y los 7 mil 400
millones de dispositivos la línea azul y
la línea roja se cruzaron la línea azul
es la población la línea roja son los
dispositivos conectados a internet y a
partir de ese año 2015 podemos ver que
esta brecha se va haciendo cada vez más
amplia cada vez más rápido de hecho cada
segundo hay 2 habitantes más en nuestro
planeta pero los dispositivos
electrónicos se están multiplicando 5
veces más rápido que nosotros con 10
nuevas conexiones a internet cada
segundo
podemos ver eso en esta apreciación
esta es una captura de pantalla de dos
páginas de internet diferentes la
primera la de azul es la página del
censo de los estados unidos que nos
muestra en tiempo real cómo está
implementándose la población del mundo
y la segunda captura de pantalla la de
abajo la del blanco esta página de
internet de la gsm que nos muestra al
mismo tiempo también en tiempo real cómo
se están multiplicando los dispositivos
móviles conectados a internet incluyendo
el internet de las cosas ahora las
proyecciones del reporte edixon es que
para el 2023 apenas cinco años más
tendremos 30 mil millones de
dispositivos conectados a internet y en
el mismo momento para el mismo año la
a-1 prevé que la población del mundo
llegará a los 8 mil millones ya en ese
momento la brecha entre dispositivos
móviles conectados a internet y seres
humanos habitando el planeta será enorme
abismal como podemos ver en esta
animación
bien aquí podemos ver como la línea se
separa y los dispositivos suben y suben
y suben y suben y siguen subiendo hasta
llegar a los 30.000 millones vean
ustedes la diferencia con el número de
pobladores bienvenidos a la cuarta
revolución industrial saben vivimos una
época fascinante pero no desprovista de
retos hay predicciones que dicen que
para el 2030 la mitad de las
universidades tradicionales habrá
desaparecido y toda actividad económica
que pueda ser automatizada lo será eso
según el instituto global mckenzie puede
impactar al 45 por ciento de nuestros
empleos como educadora no puedo dejar de
hacerme dos preguntas inquietantes en
primer lugar
como podemos preparar a nuestros niños y
jóvenes para un futuro que es
emocionante pero al mismo tiempo
demandante y incierto y por otro lado
quien va a educar a nuestros niños será
la profesión docente una de las muchas
que se predice que van a desaparecer en
la cuarta revolución industrial
será que la tecnología finalmente va a
reemplazar a los maestros precisamente
con esas inquietudes en mente un grupo
de maestros seis maestros todos ellos
finalistas al global teacher price el
premio mundial a los maestros nos
reunimos para intercambiar ideas para
compartir para pensar para reflexionar y
de esa unión surgió un libro al que
llamamos teaching in the fort industrial
revolution o la enseñanza en la cuarta
revolución industrial para escribir este
libro colaborativamente no solamente nos
basamos en nuestra propia experiencia
como educadores sino que tomamos también
en cuenta la experiencia de muchos otros
educadores reconocidos en el mundo y
también por supuesto investigadores
expertos y académicos de la educación en
cuanto a la primera pregunta que
necesitan nuestros niños y jóvenes saber
en este momento para enfrentarse a los
retos que se avecinan las respuestas de
los maestros surgieron como una sola voz
desde japón hasta finlandia desde méxico
hasta china desde australia hasta canadá
los maestros estuvieron de acuerdo las
habilidades y conocimientos que nuestros
chicos necesitan para la cuarta
revolución industrial van mucho pero
mucho más allá que la lectura las
matemáticas y las ciencias que es
entonces lo que hace falta las voces de
los maestros fueron igual de entusiastas
que de diversas y esto fue lo que
mencionaron ciudadanía global arte
música programación relaciones humanas
emprendimiento conciencia del medio
ambiente e incluso meditación
el 74% de los maestros que entrevistamos
nos reportaron que utilizan la
tecnología mucho pero mucho más de lo
que lo hacían hace 15 años sin embargo
están seguros de que la tecnología
eventualmente no va a acabar por
sustituir a los maestros y aquí uno
podría sospechar y preguntarse
será que realmente los maestros tienen
certeza académica de que la tecnología
no va a sustituir nos o será más bien
que no tenemos ni idea pero que pedimos
al cielo que no vaya a ser así porque no
queremos quedarnos en trabajo
hay que consultar entonces y considerar
otras fuentes académicos por ejemplo
michael true cano que es especialista en
educación y tecnología del banco mundial
está convencido de que la tecnología no
va a sustituir a los maestros pero sin
embargo advierte que los maestros que no
usen la tecnología finalmente serán
reemplazados por los que si lo hagan
hace algunos años me presenté en la sala
de congresos del tecnológico de
monterrey para recibir mi título de
maestría estaba terminando un posgrado y
era la primera vez que me paraba en la
universidad porque cursó la maestría
completamente en línea e incluso a mi
tesis la defendí a distancia pero saben
siempre había un ser humano del otro
lado de la computadora los cursos que
llevé los diseñaron maestros humanos mis
trabajos me los revisaron maestros
humanos recibí retroalimentación de
maestros humanos y de compañeros de
estudios que estaban en cualquier lugar
del mundo la tecnología no sustituyó a
mis maestros era maestría la tecnología
fue la plataforma que facilitó que
pudiéramos conectarnos todos para ese
trabajo y ese proyecto en conjunto ahora
veo todavía menos probable que la
tecnología pueda sustituir a los
maestros de preescolar o de primaria
pocas personas respeto yo más que las
maestras de preescolar y quizás por eso
me convertí en una de ellas
cualquier maestra de preescolar puede
decirles que un salón de clases con 20
niños de 3 años es el ambiente más
caótico e impredecible dinámico y
maravilloso que existe no importa que
tan complejos sean sus algoritmos y qué
tan sofisticado sean no importa cuántas
enciclopedias de desarrollo infantil
podamos meter en su cerebro digital ya
quisiera yo ver a un robot enseñándole a
un niño pequeño a compartir a esperar su
turno a jugar con otros niños y
consolarlo cuando se caiga y cerraste la
rodilla
lo veo sinceramente muy difícil muy muy
difícil y es que la tecnología es muy
buena para cualquier actividad que pueda
ser automatizada por ejemplo sería
perfecta para una línea de producción en
serie pero sabe cuál es el problema los
niños los jóvenes y de hecho todos los
seres humanos no somos ni muebles ni
juguetes ni mercancías que podamos ser
fabricados en masa y bajo un estándar
para nada la educación tiene que ser un
traje hecho a la medida la educación es
una labor artesanal la educación es a
veces absurda compleja increíblemente
extraña a veces pero profundamente
humana y hermosa y eso me lleva a mi
siguiente argumento educar implica
conectar
es increíblemente difícil alcanzar la
mente de un niño si no has tocado
primero su alma si no te has conmovido
con él ante el cosquilleo del reto o el
miedo al fracaso o el júbilo de la
autorrealización no es increíblemente
difícil
eduardo andere que es un escritor y
analista muy reconocido en méjico
especialista en temas de políticas
públicas y educación comparada ha
dedicado los últimos 20 años a visitar
cientos de escuelas alrededor del mundo
en países de alto desempeño académico
cuando entrevistamos para nuestro libro
él nos comentó dos constantes que ha
detectado en la última década en las
escuelas una la percepción de los
maestros y de los directores de escuela
de que los maestros somos más
importantes que la tecnología y que toda
esta idea famosa de la educación
personalizada tecnológicamente asistida
es en realidad un mito porque la
tecnología es una función
de la pedagogía y no a la inversa y la
segunda que mientras más motivados estén
los estudiantes menos serán necesarios
los ambientes sofisticados ya sean
físicos o tecnológicos porque la
motivación también es más importante que
la tecnología y esto puede ser que
sorprenda alguno de ellos algunos de
ustedes
hay investigaciones tanto de la ocde
como de el foro económico internacional
mundial como de otras instancias que
apuntan a que no existe una relación
entre mayor uso de la tecnología y las
aulas y mejor logro académico por parte
de los alumnos y saben que en algunas
ocasiones incluso es a la inversa
ahora saben que si impacta positivamente
el oro académico de los alumnos un buen
maestro y aquí tenemos un estudio de la
universidad de stanford que nos dice que
el factor que más impacta al logro
académico de los estudiantes es la
preparación de los maestros aún después
de controlar otros factores también de
mucho peso como es la pobreza y el
estatus del lenguaje el estatus del
lenguaje se refiere a la ventaja o
desventaja de vocabulario con la que ya
llega un niño a la escuela cuando inicia
la educación formal es todavía más
importante el tema de la preparación de
los maestros y con esto no quiero decir
por supuesto que los maestros le estemos
dando la espalda a la tecnología yo me
considero de hecho una entusiasta de la
tecnología y la he utilizado de muchas
maneras diferentes en el aula con mis
alumnos pero el acceso a la tecnología
seamos honestos
muy diferente de una escuela a otra
escuela incluso con los maestros
finalistas al global picture price que
son reconocidos internacionalmente por
su labor pedagógica el uso de la
tecnología es asimétrico de un aula a
otra aula y quisiera presentarles dos
ejemplos cada uno en el extremo opuesto
tenemos por ejemplo a joe padre joe
father y es un maestro de preparatoria
de illinois en eeuu él nos dice que sus
alumnos pueden crear cortometrajes
pueden hacer libros pueden componer
canciones pueden crear videojuegos
utilizando una gran variedad de
herramientas tecnológicas tienen a su
disposición impresoras 3d drones y
minecraft pero yo es muy claro y nos
dice no nos confundamos todo esto es
simplemente un conjunto de herramientas
que tienen como objetivo ayudarnos a
sacar el potencial de nuestros chicos a
que ellos puedan explotar su creatividad
pero la tecnología no va a venir a
sustituir la creatividad de nuestros
chicos puede obviamente catapultar esa
creatividad pero no es la creatividad y
por otro lado tenemos a miriam veis 11-6
miriam mason es una maestra inglesa
educada en cambridge que hace algunos
años emigró a sierra leona en aquel
entonces el país más pobre del mundo
su objetivo era fundar una escuela en la
que pudiera atender a los niños que más
lo necesitaban en este país niños
huérfanos niños soldados rescatados de
la guerra y niñas que desde muy
jovencitas desde muy pequeñas se habían
convertido en madres el día de hoy la
fundación que miriam dirige edúcate
atiende a más de 2500 chicos de primaria
y secundaria en sierra leona en 9
escuelas
aquí tenemos una imagen de uno de los
chicos de miriam y ustedes pueden verlos
muy contentos
aparentemente jugando fútbol pero ellos
están también celebrando la llegada de
este balón a la escuela porque hasta
hacía unas semanas antes de esta
fotografía ellos jugaban fútbol con un
balón hecho con bolsas de plástico
amarradas porque no tenían los recursos
para comprar balones de fútbol ellos
dependen de donativos internacionales
para subsistir por supuesto yo les
pregunto si no tienen ni siquiera para
comprar un balón creen ustedes que
tengan para tener la tecnología que ya
quisiéramos ver en muchos de los salones
por supuesto que no
miriam nos dice que de hecho la
tecnología en los salones es
prácticamente inexistente si la utilizan
las maestras para preparar sus clases
para hacer material didáctico y bueno
con los teléfonos celulares tienen
acceso a internet a veces pero en
realidad el uso es prácticamente cero no
tendrán tecnología pero afortunadamente
todavía tienen muchos árboles
a cuáles pueden treparse y yo les
pregunto cuándo fue la última vez que tú
o alguno de tus hijos se trepó a un
árbol en sierra leona el 3.5 de los
estudiantes que terminan la educación
secundaria
solamente el 3.5 acreditan los exámenes
nacionales en las escuelas de miriam el
100 por ciento lo logra esto no lo hizo
un robot esto lo hizo una persona un
grupo de personas apasionadas
entusiastas comprometidas
cuando sea grande quiero ser como miriam
mason sí sí
no la tecnología no va a sustituir a los
maestros saben por qué porque los niños
necesitan el toque artístico de la
conexión humana para desarrollar su
potencial único y eso solamente puede
darle a un padre un maestro o idealmente
ambos eso sí la marcha de la tecnología
es imparable en donde quiera que estemos
y querámoslo o no todos estamos al borde
de un cambio monumental y que podemos
hacer entonces si estamos de pie frente
al precipicio no nos queda de otra
atrevernos a volar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
a
[Música]